you are working as a behavioral
specialist with what kind of animals so
I'm the director of behavior at Toronto
Humane Society I'm an applied animal
behaviorist I work with the all the
animals at the shelter I will say though
my specialization is really in cats
that's what my PhD is but I work with
dogs cats Turtles rabbits you name it
but Turtles don't have a behavior
they're just like Oh I'm a turtle
well sometimes there are things that we
need I'm I'm munching on something and
no I'm not but now I am again I don't
understand that it doesn't make there'd
be a lot of moving Parts where the
turtle's psyche so sometimes there are
behaviors we need to encourage in our
turtles so if they don't spend a lot of
time uh on like we call it stunning it's
a fake life but uh under their sun lamp
they can get what's called shell rot so
you sometimes have to encourage the
turtles to come up and spend more time
on their sunlight so we do train the
turtles it's not like the equivalent one
of bed sores I guess so so if they don't
get enough proper light the the shell
starts to rot yeah wow okay well I guess
turtles have more going on than I
thought yeah
oh no my my house is starting to smell
crumbling around me
coming to pick up Pixar 20 or 24. thank
God you guys aren't in charge of Pixar
my turtle sounds a little like Mitch
McConnell yeah well he looks a lot like
a turtle exactly hi everybody I'm Mitch
McConnell
he's always forgetting his shell so uh
so but cats cats are your specialty and
you know a lot about cats there are two
cats that live in my house I uh they're
not my cats
um but they're cats that live in my home
well I just don't think of them as mine
because and also they don't really seem
that interested in me uh one is Thor and
the other is Cleo
um and so maybe you have some tricks for
me on how I can bond with them what are
things that cats like I've tried stuff
that I thought would work and it
wouldn't like making them really big
sandwiches
we tried lasagna yeah I picked some
really hot lasagna large portions
um where's your Garfield right yeah what
uh what um what do you suggest what are
some tricks for dealing with cats well I
mean giving them lots of food that that
is appropriate for them is a good tip
another thing we like to do is training
just teaching them to do you know stupid
pet tricks that really helps Foster your
bond and then there's this thing that uh
can work that's called uh well it's
called the slow blink or the kitty kiss
do this with my cat all the time what is
it do you yeah oh that's great so you
just kind of close your eyes gently and
open them and so normally they'll do
that to you as well it's really just a a
sign that they're they trust you and
they're willing to make themselves
vulnerable around you and so if you if
they do it to you and you do it back to
them then it's kind of a language that
the two of you can develop together and
really sort of have this communal
understanding of what you're saying
that's so weird because when I was
single I did this to women at bars oh
God I was often escorted off the
property yeah yeah it never worked the
slow blank it's a different species is
that a different thing yeah yeah I
forgot it was for cats I can't see you
slowly blinking at your cats I feel like
you just don't have the patience I think
you're slow blinking I can't slow blink
everything I do is fast quick you know I
mean everything oh God no I don't mean
what did you think I meant sex yeah
that's what I meant oh oh yeah that's
what we're that's what we're responding
oh of course yeah oh yeah no it's
exactly very quick and unsatisfying for
everyone oh yeah over in seconds it's
not that's I've made that clear right
yeah oh yeah Lightning Fast yeah like it
never even happened no one feels a thing
anyway glad we cleared that up no it
feels not even you oh no I feel nothing
no one feels anything no one no one do
it it's one of those things you gotta do
you know it's like why'd you climb
Everest because it was there you know
hey uh so I'm gonna try slow blinking at
these cats tonight but I'm telling you
these cats are not into me this is why
you and correct me if I'm wrong if you
slow blink and then you put your hand
down open up and let the cat come to you
and before long you're bonded and you
can do little head bumps that's what I
do with mine it's nice you know here's
the thing Thor I get along with better
that's the dude Cleo very skittish
incredibly skittish cat and Cleo loves
my daughter and just wants to hang out
with her all the time and now that she's
away at College she's around the house
and I'm trying really hard to bond with
her but I she acts as if I murdered her
in another life and wants nothing to do
with me and I don't know how to break
this this uh this terrible terrible
still mate with Cleo well what's your
current strategy is it fast motions and
blinking at it really quickly yeah
that's the problem is I move really
quickly and uh if I don't immediately
get affection I throw a sneaker her at
them oh yeah maybe at least go for a
slipper something slightly softer no no
I don't I would never hurt an animal
let's make that clear right now so
there's no phone calls
they love it when I intentionally
misunderstand that this is a podcast if
you're listening right now don't you'll
call in
uh well Jackie we learned a lot we
learned a lot and I'm gonna try all of
this that you just said with Cleo
tonight